las negociaciones entre la delegación
ucraniana y rusa se han paralizado por
hoy pero continuarán mañana sobre la
mesa un alto al fuego temporal y los
corredores humanitarios que no han
funcionado hasta el momento sobre el
terreno aquí en ucrania la guerra sigue
siguen los ataques sobre todo en la
capital en kiev en los suburbios se
están bombardeando edificios de civiles
y preocupa mucho la situación de
mariupol hoy el ejército ni extremis ha
podido sacar a un grupo de ciudadanos la
ciudad está sitiada tiene problemas de
acceso al agua la comida incluso los
camiones de ayuda humanitaria están
teniendo problemas para poder entrar hay
más ciudades sitiadas en este país no
solo mariupol también está ir pin schumi
o hartkopf incluso el portavoz del
kremlin ha asegurado que el plan ruso
continúa y que están dispuestos a tomar
el control de más ciudades en este país